The last part about human resources are qualified employees
and the culture you set for your company.
Qualified employees are the difference between a good idea
that never went anywhere and a billion dollar firm.
It gets a million times but it's very true.
A employees in a B market will always win over B employees in an A market.
Hopefully, your A employees in an A market and you'll be figuring out where
to put the bags of money, but you want to always hire people better than you,
and if that's threatening to you as a founder or if that's threatening to any of your employees,
the system kind of collapses from there.
You want people who actually can see farther than you or have skills deeper than you,
and that's the sign of a world-class founder.